[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
who asked his girlfriend's dad can i
marry your daughter and he said no
we also talked to a wife and mother
whose relationship is headed towards
divorce and she's stuck and afraid
and we also talk about choosing guilt
over resentment how hard that is stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
yo yo yo what's up that's a bit much
coming in hot this morning
i don't know what time it is but i'm
sorry james
kelly her eyebrows shot up like
that was too much sorry
i'm gonna do this again good morning
everybody welcome to the john dolone
show where we talk about joy and
laughter and i don't know what's going
on man hope you all are doing well thank
you for joining us
um there's a billion podcasts you chose
this one we're glad that you're here so
good james kelly how are you doing
a little tired still yeah coming back
slowly
my shoulders hurt from carrying the
weight
but beyond that i'm good
well
after the show yesterday james and i
identified you as the potential super
spreader who's trying to take over the
show
because you want to be the
producer and the talent i want to be the
next you
the bar is low i get it i get it
but james and i are on to you now we see
what's happened
and um it's good to see you
nothing just eating your breakfast back
there like you don't even care nothing
hey so before we get going i want to do
a quick
response something i got on the internet
yesterday
so um we put one of those things up
asking me any kind of questions and
this idea of resentment and guilt came
up and i just mentioned as a throwaway
line choose guilt over resentment i got
a ton of
responses to that question what do you
mean choose guilt over resentment what
does that mean and people ask me i'm
always telling people that resentment is
the end right that's the death of a
relationship that's usually the death of
your your your work environment
and so always telling people choose
guilt over resentment and i've seen that
popping up in popular like pop
psychology books over the last um year
or two choose guilt over resentment
here's what that means here's an example
of what that means
let's say that you're
you go to thanksgiving at your mom's
house last year
and you go to thanksgiving and it's a
disaster
everybody's just complaining and whining
and it's covered this and politics that
and you
you and
your kids you and whoever you're married
to whoever like we're done we're never
doing that again
ever
and then fast forward to this year
and it's august it's september it's
october
and mom shoots the text and says hey
thanksgiving is going to be on this day
at our house
and you inhale sharply
like oh man i'm not doing that i said i
wasn't gonna do that
this is when you choose guilt over
resentment
this is when you text back and say we're
gonna be doing thanksgiving as a small
family unit this year i'm gonna be doing
a friend's giving
with my friends here in my local city
and i'm not gonna be able to make it i'm
gonna be doing something with my local
church i'm gonna be doing something with
my workplace i'm gonna be down at the
mission
uh serving thanksgiving lunch for
homeless folks whatever it is you say no
and then you know what's coming
the tears the drama the
oh i'm sorry that oh is it because uh
all that and then you feel guilty that
you told your mom no that you broke your
mom's heart whatever you stories you
choose to tell yourself about that
situation
or the other alternative is is you say
and you don't answer
and then you send some text to your
brothers and sisters you send a text to
your dad you complain about it to your
friends you whine about it but you know
what's gonna happen you know i'm gonna
end up going i'm just gonna go
and then you get close to time and she
says haven't heard back anything just
still making sure we're having dinner
tomo
on thanksgiving day at four o'clock
we're gonna have this evening
lunch dinner combo thing that nobody
really likes but that's just what we do
and then you look at your husband you
look at your wife you look at your
girlfriend and you're just like i guess
we're going
and then you are huffy and whiny the
whole week leading up to it
you put off work stuff until the last
possible minute so that you're
frantically packing to go
you drive you complain about the gas
prices you wind up we don't get any
snacks we're just gonna eat crap food
all the way and then you get there
and then mom starts in on politics and
covet and whatever and here we are again
and then you know you're not going to
get any sleep because you don't sleep
good on the couch and you're on the pull
out cause the kids get th
and it just starts and so you go
and you resent the whole thing you
resent the food you resent the
invitation you resent the cramped
conditions the time of lunch and you
just resent up until the time you resent
the whole trip and then you're exhausted
on the way back and you're whining and
you're complaining about
and so what you're doing when you choose
resentment is you're choosing misery
you are choosing
dysfunctional relationships you're just
choosing to put coins in that slot i'm
just gonna choose misery choose misery
choose misery and so what i want people
to begin to do
is have boundaries and choose guilt over
resentment choose the guilt you're gonna
feel by holding that boundary choose
guilt by saying no
choose guilt that when your local church
says hey will you come teach sunday
school and you just go no you instantly
go i should have gone i should have done
it or when your husband says hey i
really want to go eat here tonight and
you know that that food gives you rocket
diarrhea you're not gonna go
and just say no i don't feel like eating
there tonight i want to eat here
that's better than choosing to just go
okay whatever i'm going and then be
resentful of him be resentful of the
restaurant be resentful of the wait
staff of the babysitter being resentful
of everything so
what i want you to do is look around
your life
find those places where you have chosen
resentment where you continue to do
things that make you miserable and that
when you show up you choose to be
miserable while you're there
i want you to find those places in your
life and say no begin to draw boundaries
around those things
and choose guilt over resentment because
here's what you're gonna find guilt
won't kill you
never has never will
and you're gonna find that wait a minute
guilt didn't kill me and i'm actually
stronger for having had a boundary in
holding it and now i've got to deal with
the relational impact of this
because i'm not the peacekeeper here
uh it's not my job to make sure
everybody else is okay and me just
resent them all the time
so i i don't want to eat taco bell again
i'm gonna say no i'm gonna feel a little
bit guilty because i drew this boundary
i get that and now i'm gonna have to
deal with
the imbalance in my marriage i'm gonna
have to deal with the imbalance of my
dating relationship or my kids say can i
have can i can i can i can you just say
no you cannot i'm gonna feel that weird
pain of guilt because i told my kid no
and i'm gonna wonder where does that
guilt come from and i'm gonna start
tracing that back i'm gonna do the hard
work i'm gonna find out where that guilt
i'm gonna free myself from that over
time
but you're gonna find that you get
stronger and stronger every time you
stare guilt down
you realize i can do hard stuff i can
i'm stronger than i thought i was i need
to get a friend to help me with this one
cause i feel really guilty by telling my
mom no i feel really guilty by not going
to do whatever dad wants to do again and
again and again
choose guilt over resentment every time
every time
and then watch how powerful and strong
you become and watch where you have to
start dealing with some of the stories
you've been telling yourself for years
and years and years
so that's choose guilt over resentment
hope that helps all right let's go to
gabriel in toronto
what's up gabriel
hey man i'm good how are you i'm
outstanding brother how we doing
yeah yeah i'm doing all right all right
man so what's up how can i help
yeah so
uh
i would like to propose to my girlfriend
uh but when i spoke to her dad sometime
around march
he
did not give me his blessing to take her
hand in marriage oh no he said no
yeah he said no
um
dude and that was in march tell me how
that was
how did how did the conversation go
did this shock you or did you know this
was coming
no you know what i didn't know what to
expect so i guess it kind of did shock
me um i just asked him like
yeah we know we've known each other for
this time and i have this much money
um and he's like oh yeah that that
amount can uh buy you a trip like just
buy your flight ticket
basically said i have no money
i don't have an education
and just want he said to chill for five
years
for five years
yeah that's what he told her yeah that's
what he told her all right so you
wow
uh i one day i gotta check with him and
make sure he's cool that i tell that
story one day i'll tell the story on the
show about when i asked my father-in-law
if i could marry his daughter it's
outstanding his response to me and by
outstanding like i still shiver but um
so you
this he just got outright no
so you called us dude did you call him
did you go in person
please tell me he was in person nah so
she she lives in a different country so
i have to call him okay so you call him
and he just says no and then do you
circle back to her does she know this
exchange happened
yeah yeah
so so what does she say i'm out or
forget that guy oh yeah i mean she gets
pretty emotional about it well i would
imagine so
i'm kind of at a loss i haven't heard of
this happening very often um and so
does she want to still go through with
this thing i mean how can i help let me
let me say it that way
yeah yeah so
she does like she wants to
like she wants me to propose she wants
to get married
um but you know i always heard like
i i obviously i want to respect like her
dad's blessing i mean it's his
daughter right
um but
so the kind of the problem is is that
she he
doesn't really treat uh her her family
the best
and she's she told me that he has like
um some narcissistic um
traits what's the culture right and
uh so he's nigerian okay um so a lot of
like i mean i'm not saying all nigerians
are like but
it provides cultural context there yeah
um yeah it's like a lot of pride um you
need to be stable have an education like
that's a must or else you're stupid
right well
that's not just nigerian that's that's
many many many cultures right
um so you asked for this blessing you
didn't get it
and
were you really asking for it or were
you trying to do the thing that you
thought you were supposed to do and that
of course he was gonna say yes welcome
to the family
or were you really asking
because if you were really asking he
said no
if you were doing it more as a romantic
gesture
and
now you got some input that you weren't
really asking for
um that's and that's a whole other track
so were you really asking or no
uh
i would have liked to have his blessing
before so i guess yes okay
um
yeah but i asked it in march and then
now it's now i'm gonna see her in
september okay
um
so it's kind of like a while and i was
uh
i have her mom's blessing he said he
said five years man you've given it like
three months
yeah
so it's
not the greatest timeline so let's let's
back out for a second is he right okay
do you have no money
do you not have an education do you not
have her best interest in in mind
so i i don't i
i made a plan to not go to
post-secondary
entrepreneurship okay um
and are you actually are you actually
pursuing entrepreneurship are you just
one of those guys that does a lot of
like googling
and you want to be like a
like like a halfway day trader because i
got an idea and i got a lot of money in
bitcoin or are you actually working 130
hours a week to get a new small business
off the ground
um so
i have been but like not 130 hours or
whatever but i have like um a few
businesses but i was i wanted to start
something
on the ground once i move
so i don't just start something here and
then have to leave you know
um
you're not in school you're not working
you're entrepreneuring why don't you
just move now and get going
because it's really hard to uh get a
permit
uh get a visa
absolutely and if yep
yeah if we got married um it would just
i would get it instantly
uh
soon avoid that
man this whole thing's getting messier
by the second
yeah
so
how old are you
21. 21.
do you want to marry this girl because
you love her or do you want to marry
this girl cause she's gonna
get you
located uh relocated faster
oh no because i love her how long have
you all been together i i wouldn't care
where where we went uh
about a year and a few months now what's
the rush
uh
i think we kind of just want to start
our life together i mean this is all
mutual by the way it's not just me like
wanting a visa wanting like all this
stuff i know that that could sound bad
but yeah we just kind of want to start
our life together um you know start
living together
um
she's starting a business too so i'll
help her with hers
i guess we just want to
start our life you know
and he wants to move out of the house i
want to move out
yeah
ultimately
there's a couple things at play here and
some of this you're not asking me but
i'm telling you anyway
if you're gonna quote unquote commit to
a life of entrepreneurship
i can tell
by your
voice
you're not there yet
because committing to a life of
entrepreneurship isn't just i got a
couple of businesses i'm starting
i'm just going to sell shoes on ebay
does that work yes there's a thing and
blah blah
be committed to an idea
to making this thing work
to adding value and good in the world
and dude that
that purpose that why that drive should
have you up before any of your neighbors
and should have you working way into the
night
in that there's an entrepreneurial ethos
when you're around real entrepreneurs
you can feel it on them
and it isn't something that you do to
avoid college or i got a couple ideas
man i'm just thinking about because i
know those guys too
and they're they're just wet blankets
they're just sad drippy
i don't do they just i'm like my
shoulders are
egging up right now
does that make sense
and so if you're gonna commit to that
there will be a fire in you
like a fire yeah
and
that will make its way through the
telephone
that will be somebody that dads want you
around right because you have a zest for
life you've got a zest for adding value
to other people
especially and foremost
that guy's daughter okay so you didn't
ask me about that
if i want you to hang up his phone and
sit down and actually say what do i want
to do and it shouldn't like just sitting
around wait until you move or i want to
start get going today man get going
today and if you build up a bunch of
clients and then a year later you're
married and you're living in a new
country or a new town awesome the skills
you'll have learned now will translate
directly where you are whatever that
hustle is that grind is the how to get
funding is the hours where all of it
will will nothing will be a waste
nothing
okay
so that's unsolicited as it comes to his
daughter is a simple simple thing
he said no
he said wait five years
and so y'all can either get married no
he he doesn't have his blessing
depending on who he is the cultural
implications where he lies in his family
all that stuff he may cut you out
forever
and if y'all are good with that then be
good with that
go into it with um with eyes wide open
or he may have been blowing smoke at you
just to see what kind of man you are
and you get married and he gets really
pissed off and then you really show him
how much you love his daughter
what kind of good you're adding to your
local community to her life to the world
to that family and then he comes around
and then in 5 or 10 or 15 or 20 years
this is a funny story that y'all tell at
you know at
religious holidays
um
or
you hold off
that i mean that's what it comes down to
so is she willing to say forget this guy
i'm out of my dad's house i'm moving out
um i don't care what he has to say i've
got my mom's blessing that's good enough
for me let's get married
yep okay then what are you waiting for
something's holding you back uh
i mean i i'm planning to do it in
september so
uh not much has hold me back i just
wanted to get
some some wisdom and insight i guess
right
yeah at the end of the day she's not
property
she's her own person
yeah
and
dad said no
and it's gonna be hard
okay it's gonna be tough
and so don't think it's just gonna be
this ah be all good it may not
he may cut you all out
hopefully he doesn't
here's what i would do if i were you
okay here's what i would do
if i asked my father-in-law
hey can i have your daughter's hand in
marriage and he said no you can't i
don't think you're i think you're a bum
i think you're lazy um i haven't seen
that you love her you're 21 you're a kid
you've only been dating her for a year
um
no y'all aren't ready for that
and then you stat stings and you go back
to her and she gets upset and you're
upset
and then you decide you know what i'm
gonna do it anyway
four or five months later here's what i
would do out of respect
i would write him a letter
hand the written letter no i'd probably
type this one i'd type this one
i'd write him a letter
and say
i want you to know i've taken your words
into account and i'm grateful for your
perspective
here's the things that i'm doing here's
here's how i love your daughter here's
my commitments to your daughter here's
my commitment to your family i am
choosing to go forward and ask her to
marry me
i do have your wife's blessing i hope
that in time you and i can come together
and have a
great relationship i do understand that
i'm going forward
without your blessing i hope to earn or
i hope that you will give me your
blessing in time
and that way you are looking him back
like you i'd eye him and y'all did over
the phone but you said can i have the
most precious thing in your world and he
said no
and now what you're saying is i'm taking
it
and um i am going to join join um your
family
i am um not taking it because you don't
own her either um
i am going to co-create a world
together with your daughter
and i want you to know that i respect
you and i appreciate it your insight and
input and i hope that in time i can earn
your blessing
but i'm moving forward
and that way there's no secret there's
no hiding there's no you ducked into a
corner and just did this thing no you
stood back up
you have enough courage to override the
blessing that you asked for that you
didn't get
um but you all need to have clear eyes
about what this relationship's gonna
look like without dad
he may not go to the wedding he may not
fund the wedding he may tell all the
brothers and sisters y'all are forbidden
to go and some of it may not go all
those things make sure you have your
eyes wide open
please go to a pre-marriage counselor
talk about this stuff
because it's gonna be hard on your wife
especially if she loves her and respects
her dad this is a hard
rock and a hard place she's found
herself between right
so please go to premarital counseling
get some insight into this and best of
luck to you brother let me know how it
goes i am interested if you're going to
go ahead and propose in the next month
or so and i guess when the shows come
out it'll be right about when you're
doing this let me know how it goes write
me back and i'd love to hear about
um does he come around or does he cut
you all out or what happens next
but kudos to you for your bravery
brother stand up on both feet and
looking back in the eye and um take the
high road make sure he's got something
to hold in his hand all right we'll be
right back on the dr john dolone's show
you always hear me talking about how
good deep sleep impacts your anxiety
your depression your attitude your
mental health your physical health your
work performance sleep is critical to
every single thing in your life and if
you want to change the way you sleep you
first start with a world class mattress
one that you can actually afford and you
know i only recommend things that me and
my family use in our home and that's why
i partnered with dream cloud mattress
dream cloud gives you premium
world-class materials in a mattress at
half the price they utilize innovative
sleep signs to build mattresses that
keep you cool that support you in any
position and it adapts to your body i
made sure they have price points for
every budget dream cloud is for you they
are currently running their biggest
offer ever a total of 650 bucks in
betting and cash savings exclusive for
dr john dolone show listeners they also
have a 365 day home trial sleep on it
for a year and if you don't like it send
it back visit
dreamcloudsleep.com get 650 in savings
and goodies and start sleeping today
all right we're back let's go to kathy
in topeka kansas what's up kevi
hi dr john how are you i'm rocking on
how are you
really freaking nervous
ah don't be nervous hey can you talk
directly into the phone it sounds like
you're on speaker phone
i'm not on speaker uh there we go okay
now you're back
okay all right don't be nervous listen i
don't know what i'm doing either so
we're both making this up as we go so
you're good you're good okay we both
know that's not true so what's up how
can i help
um to stick to
what kelly told me to do um
listen all of our lives are better when
we just do what kelly tells us to do
okay this is
a good rule of life i actually have that
tattooed on my forearm do what kelly
says
that's a good idea
um okay so basically um
the last seven years of my marriage
basically the whole time i've been
married has been a roller coaster and
kind of the same cycle of stuff
um which i know we'll dig into in a
minute but um the last few weeks some
boundaries that we have set
um have been intentionally violated
and
i just
literally in the last 24 hours
that cycle has shifted to the next phase
and now
i feel like i'm being too harsh or rigid
or unreasonable
by demanding
dramatic change
so you're talking very cryptically about
cycles and things and roller coasters
and
ponies and dragons
like be specific for seven years what
has happened
has he been cheating on you is he an
addict is he abusive like for seven
years you've been dealing with what
like all of it um
so so he's been cheating on you for
seven years
no not um not constantly no and not
and not
so there was there was one affair that i
know for sure um and i know that he's
had other emotional affairs okay
um
whether or not they're physical i don't
honestly know okay um he
a couple weeks before we got married
tells me that
bipolar disorder runs in his family okay
um
and that's not surprising um he comes
from a line of alcoholics so
that has been so he's an alcoholic
sometimes when he will admit it but yes
okay
um he came uh about a year and a half or
so into our marriage two years in our
marriage he got actually in a
horrible motorcycle accident where he
almost died because he was under the
influence okay um we've been married for
seven years in literally every year if
not more often
like the first few years that he was
really drinking heavily um like we would
separate we've separated
separate physically separated like he's
moved out of the house twice and we've
been on the brink of divorce every year
for
seven years
um so what has kept you together
um
every once in a while um
like when when we've separated we've
started to go to counseling okay
um so he has done that
a couple of years ago he
started to look into
being
evaluated
for um
depression
anxiety bipolar you know things like
that and he just kind of fell through
the cracks
um so you're doing a lot of talking
about him
i'm asking i've done that too i'm asking
you why have you stayed in this marriage
through an affair through an alcoholic
through what i
can only imagine is he doesn't come home
some nights through a couple of
separations where y'all said we gotta
get away from each other
why have you stayed in this marriage for
seven years
well after the first time it was
i knew that i
i didn't help the situation like i've
never been um i've never
been around an alcoholic in my life
um up until we got together so you
already you already dumped it back on
him i'm asking you
what
you've been a part of the challenges in
the house right house
how so
well
partially because i didn't know what i
would stop just tell me
this is your life kathy this is your
life you are in the epicenter of your
life own it the good stuff and the ugly
stuff
what have you contributed that in your
mind do you feel like you've contributed
that meant you should stay that you
played a role in this thing so i gotta i
gotta i'm i'm sentenced to living in
this thing
i mean i guess i just knew that don't
guess don't guess just say it
it wasn't giving it mild like i wasn't
being patient i wasn't
doing everything that i could i knew
there were challenges within me
language have you have you had an affair
have you cheated on him no no i have not
are you an alcoholic
no are you abusive
no
i
i can be condescending okay okay
um
i can be a know-it-all okay
um
you know even just
a couple days ago like conversations
like
i can be i guess i can be i i can be
demanding okay um
you know i'm not always patient
so
over the last seven years would it be
fair to say that in some times
you've been more his mom than his wife
oh totally totally
that's i mean and i've again that's
i've been in counseling off and on you
know for five years sure um trying not
to be that i know that i've taken
too much responsibility like looked at
what it because
when the arguments happen it's always
well you may he he will tell me well you
made me do this because you keep running
your mouth
and that's that's a gaslighting nonsense
and you know that i know
i know and conversely
he's not making you do anything either
right now you know and i know i'm
oversimplifying this
right right
what i'm trying to get you to do is
these things get so tangled up
and you everything gets all wound up
together the good stuff and my guess is
when things are good they are
unbelievable
when you finally take off mom hat and
i'll even say when you're able to take
off your mom hat right somebody's got to
pay the bills and put food on the table
and make sure you're not living in a
pigs i get that
and someone's gonna make sure that idiot
goes to work and somebody's gotta hug
that guy when he's sick right right and
vice versa when he is on he's not using
he is
probably
incredibly loving and committed right is
that fair
like right now in a day he's like it's
all puppy dog face there you go yeah
there you go i love you and i'm like but
that's right about the last three weeks
that's right that's right so listen
these things get so tangled up and it's
hard to pull apart which part i own and
which part i just deal with and how much
of this is truthful and how much of this
is not and it just becomes a mess
right and then it becomes well if he
would just fill in the blank and then he
is saying to himself well if she would
just fill in the blank and you get in
this this
someone's just got to stop the dance
you've heard me say that before
somebody's gotta stop the dance turn the
music off and just say what is happening
and these things go in these cycles
because the goods are so good
and we allow that to cloud over all the
bads
and
the bads can be so bad that we let them
cloud over the good stuff
and we just find ourselves stuck in this
this inactivity right we're just frozen
so something happened a couple of days
ago where you said enough is enough is
enough what was it
well we've so we've been um
we
started with a new counselor um about a
year ago okay and we set down some
pretty firm boundaries well and firm
boundaries
um one of which is because when he gets
angry about
anything he
automatically is i'm gonna leave or i
want to divorce or
you know obviously because that's been
part of that cycle
and so
um
you know for the last year everything
like we've been you know doing okay
working through
you know issues as they come up and that
sort of thing um
but three weeks ago he
got mad at something absolutely
ridiculous
um
you know we're trying to get the boat
back um
onto the trailer with my my oldest son
who is
20
and he
didn't do something right because it was
the second time on the boat and he
he got upset he was like well this is
why we never take it out this is i'm
just gonna sell the thing you know just
starts going off so he has a temper
tantrum like a child
right okay and so i'm like all i said at
that moment was you know hey just calm
down
and
like just chill out and so when we got
home
and our child that we have together he
went inside
um
how old is that
he's six okay
almost seven
and so
um he went inside
why are you mad at me because he's um
and that's funny because i literally
just heard you yesterday you know
silence and violence and
silent treatment is like the thing okay
and so he'd given me the silent
treatment and again that's one of those
things that we're trying to fix
and
um
i was like why are you mad at me and he
just goes off he's about how nobody
appreciates the luxuries that he pays
for because he owns them
person i know i mean i can't get him to
stop working usually
because he's an addict
exactly he's addicted to that as much as
anything else but though so then we get
the wah wah wah what was me nobody
appreciates the right okay
and then he says
um he's obviously i'm gonna sell the
boat and i said okay sell it because
nobody
likes it when you turn into a bleep
every time we take it out
and
that was helpful good job right
i i didn't i didn't claim it adam
it doesn't matter
exactly but you're like sweet a little
fire i'll throw some gas on it so you
threw gas and then what
and then he told me to pack my stuff and
get out okay so i
just kind of
and it did escalate a little bit more
but i just i stopped talking after that
point and then the next morning i
um
was making breakfast because you know we
go to church every sunday whatever and
so
i sent our son in to get him for
breakfast and he didn't come and so i
went in and i just kind of
plopped on the bed and pretended like
nothing happened
and
i said are you gonna come eat breakfast
and he says
no i'll do it my darn something like i
do everything else and i'm like okay so
we're still there today
and i said
you know i was like did you mean what
you said because
we've promised each other this has been
a thing that we're not just gonna you
know throw this stuff around yeah and he
said he said well i wasn't drunk and my
blood sugar wasn't high so yeah so
here's the thing okay
this is the life you've chosen for
yourself
and it's not changing
right
and so at the end of the day you have to
have your or what statement
and more so for you
you've got a six-year-old little boy
absorbing this that this is how men
handle problems
this is how dads handle problems this is
what marriage relationships look
like this is what um how grown-ups act
they threaten each other
with
what i think is um the worst thing you
can do to somebody which is to cut
relationships that's what get out means
right
right
that what you have done who you are so
bad
i am severing that relationship with you
and your son is absorbing this
as life this is how this works and kathy
this is how stuff rolls down generation
after generation after generation
and for some reason
the roller coaster ride has been enough
for you to hang on there
and i'm not telling you to get out of
this thing
i'm not telling you to stay in this
thing
i'm telling you that you're getting the
life that you allow
and you are living the life that you
in the
that you are continuing
and if you've been going to counseling
for seven years with multiple different
counselors
and here we are seven years later and
your husband got frustrated trying to
put a boat on a trailer i've been there
it's the worst right it's the worst
but that was enough
to make him act like a five-year-old or
when he started to act like a
five-year-old his wife said hey will you
chill which happens to me regularly and
i have to make a uh
um a decision
am i gonna double down on being an idiot
or am i gonna breathe and look at my son
who's wide-eyed staring at me and i'm
gonna say dude i'm sorry i know we're
trying to figure this out your dad's a
[ __ ]
or am i gonna
use silence as violence
and huff and puff and stand around my
house
does that make sense
sure this is the life
so the question you gotta ask yourself
is am i done with this or is this gonna
just be my life
and if it's just gonna be your life
let me let me say it this way you can't
change him
you can't
you can only control you
that's it and it's scary and it's
frustrating and it's hard
if you're gonna stay
be all in when you stay work hard on
yourself do what you can do in this
situation
and if you are married to a guy who
rolls over every month and becomes a
bear
and choose
i'm avoiding him
or if you're gonna leave go
right now you've got one foot out and
one foot in
and so you are having this
wavering life your kid can't stand
firmly you're not standing firmly your
husband's not standing firmly
but i don't
i consider threats
abusive
especially relational threats
i consider
ignoring somebody abusive
that
i consider that abusive
and so the abuse in your house has to
stop i consider when you
lob grenades back at him because you
know he's spun out and he's exhausted
and and and you that's not cool either
what your house desperately needs is a
big dose of grown-ups and neither of
y'all are acting like grown-ups
i'm not saying that uh you have you you
haven't earned it i mean it you it's
been a rough
go i get that
but that house is desperate people
acting like grownups
and there's none
until the end of the day here's what i'm
telling you you can't control them you
can't you can only control you
threats are abusive silence can be
abusive
everybody gets dirt going up acting like
grown-ups and you gotta deal with you
if you're going to stay be all in if
you're going to go go
[Music]
don't be switzerland here on this one
we'll be right back on the dr john dolan
show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right we are back hey kelly you've
put this email on here um i don't let's
let's not take one more call i want to
answer this email here you put on here
the last
20 or 30 shows
so eventually
we'll get eventually you'll get to it
we'll get to it um usually when you put
an email in here it it comes up with
some regularity so here's here is the
email from lisa
lisa writes my sister just experienced a
bitter divorce
she's asked me to help her with this
symbolic funeral as part of her healing
while i understand the why i don't get
the how what sort of things should we do
or say
okay so here's what i take into
consideration when i'm having a ceremony
so you all have heard me say that over
and over have some sort of ceremony and
i love this question lisa because this
is getting into the
all right delonay you say all these
things all the time what does that
actually look like
here's the beauty of this it can look
like
anything so i'm thinking back to
little ceremonies i've had in my life
when i left a job and i wasn't leaving
on the best terms
when i
um have relationships i haven't let go
of when i'm dealing with childhood
traumas right
all these ceremonies quote unquote look
different
sometimes they include one person
and it might be me writing a letter to
my childhood self and reading it in
front of my wife she's somebody i trust
or reading it in front of my buddy todd
or in front of my buddy john right
whatever that looks like
it might be
going and having
um a drink with
kevin and michael on somebody's back
porch kevin's got an awesome
thing in his back
and i just said hey guys i just need to
say some stuff out loud can you just
listen
and they go yeah
and then i just say
this happened at this job and i still
carry this thing around and i need to
let this thing go and so i'm just using
this marker guys i'm just letting it go
and kevin's somebody who will inevitably
say what good are you taking from it
and
which i think is a great question so
we'll get there here at the end
i've done things where the lights are
really low and it's almost like a seance
of sorts i've done things with full
um fluorescent lights on and i've packed
up stuff in a box and i've taken it and
given it away i've torn things out of
journals and put them in my fire pit
outside
i'm big on marking things as before and
after so i can have these touchstones
that say this hurt this sucked i got
stuck here
and now this officially marks the first
day of what comes next right this is the
period at the end of the sentence is
what i tell myself
and so here's two important things to
keep in mind number one
it happened
and so marking it with
the good stuff and
number two the bad stuff
what we often do in these situations is
make them all somebody passed away let's
say
it's all the great stuff it's all we're
gonna miss them they were this and
wonderful and blah blah
it's important to also talk about the
negative stuff even if they're not that
negative right maybe it's um they they
were abusive and they were a great
husband but man they could get angry
and he passed away suddenly
you got to heal from both of those
things right you're going to miss the
good stuff and you're going to exhale
because now you're gonna have to learn
to live without that tension
because your house suddenly is a lot
more calm
and it's a lot more scary because
because he also kept you safe but all
right so it's both hand or it may just
be that he always left those little
whiskers when he shaved and they were
just everywhere
like
all over the bathroom and you know what
you're not gonna have to clean that up
anymore it's good to mark those things
and so it's marking the humanity parts
the good stuff and the bad stuff you
worked a job and you just get fired or
you work a job and you just beat you up
and beat you up and you finally get a
new one
and you're gonna have to move and you're
looking at the certificates you got
you've got this pack of pay stubs you
don't even know why you kept on but you
did
you've got this training that you went
through so you got a certification but
you don't all of that stuff you sit down
and you can do that one by yourself you
can do that with a friend you can get it
with a spouse you can do it with your
kids right
but it's sitting down and saying
what am i not gonna miss about this
what did i learn from this
and what are some good stuff i got from
here i learned how to deal with hard
conversations i learned that i can get
fired and i wake up the next day and i'm
still breathing that's good
i learned that i can dump my entire life
into a job and over the next 24 hours it
all goes away and so who am i i'm not
gonna ever let my identity get wrapped
up in a job title again right
it's just taking full ownership of these
things and sometimes you will weep
bitterly sometimes you will laugh like
crazy sometimes you'll do both sometimes
you'll just have to exhale deeply
sometimes you're going to keep a little
a little a little trinket
sometimes you're gonna realize you know
i dated that person for five years they
are a part of me i dated them for two
years
and i loved them i went all in and it
didn't work
and i remember how good it feels when
you go all in on something i also
remember how bad it hurts when you go
all in and doesn't end up um
you know being for the rest of our life
so i'm going to keep this little thing
that we got on that one trip or i'm
going to keep this one letter and the
rest of the stuff i'm going to throw
away
or i'm going to get it all out of my
house i'm going to clean it all out all
right i'm going to write down and we're
going to put this in a fire we're going
to put over a candle and we're going to
burn it
i had one person that i worked with that
wrote a letter to his dad
um wrote a letter to his brother that
had taken his own life
and then went out to a firing range and
shot holes all through it
he was a big gun collector
it could be any number of ways to do
this there's not a right or wrong other
than
process the good
process the negative
put a period at the end of that sentence
and one thing that can become really
powerful in this moment this is adding
on to it is
a short commitment to yourself whether
it's a set of affirmations that just say
i'm still breathing
this hurts more than life itself but i'm
still here
i don't know what tomorrow's gonna look
like but i'm okay i'm stronger than i
thought i was right so whatever that set
of affirmations are
and if you're with somebody and you're
up for it you can turn this into a
here's my commitment for the next 30
days
i'm going to move my body i'm going to
exercise i'm going to call somebody i'm
going to write a letter i'm going to
whatever i'm going to do this for the
next 30 days and so it ends up being a
a recognition
of the good stuff a recognition and
ownership of the bad stuff a period at
the end of that sentence a set of
affirmations i'm still breathing i'm
still here
i'm not breathing well this is scary but
i'm here
and then it can be and here's what the
next 30 days cause that's all you know
right you don't like i'm gonna make a
life where i'm you don't know man
lifeguard just got hard maybe you have
to work three jobs now because someone
you love just left or you're moving out
like the last caller you finally say you
know what enough is enough i'm out
and i'm going to mourn the good stuff
one of the best stuff and then here's
what's next for me
so those are some ideas it can look like
anything
but make sure you keep those boundaries
there and if at all possible you've
heard me say this i'll say it over and
over i'll say it again again grief
demands to be witnessed right so doing
this with other people whether it's one
person two person five people just on
somebody's back porch or you're looking
directly into somebody's eyes
grief demands to be witnessed right so
great question lisa i hope that helps um
try something in your life try a
symbolic funeral
my daughter missed the first week of
kindergarten this past week all excited
we have you know all my wife's a teacher
i've been a teacher we know how
important the first week of kindergarten
is where they make friends that you know
it's all that she missed it and so we're
having to have a ceremony in our house
me and my wife just because we're
mourning it just
ah man
that's gonna be tough to be tough on my
daughter it's gonna be tough because she
got sick so
what's that gonna look like right and so
just owning that um try a small symbolic
funeral as part of your healing pick
something that's happened whether it's
coveted whether it's politics whether
it's whatever relational stuff pick
something
and commit to a small ceremony try it
out practice it and then see how you
feel the next morning as you move on
with your life all right as we wrap up
today's show
us this guy's a good buddy of mine i've
been waiting
like his records are so so good he's a
close close friend he's an incredible
painter um incredible artist he lives
here in nashville he's been a buddy of
mine for about 20 years
um he wants somebody to check out man
it's eric peters i'm good he's just an
extraordinary artist
but office 20 2006 his 2006 record it's
called scarce
scarce scarce
it's the last song on the record and
it's a song that that gets me every time
i hear it
it's called the long road to nowhere and
it goes like this
there's a feeling that i get you're not
done with me yet
but i go to bed at night feeling lost
it's dangerous i know i could go out on
my own and run away and never come back
but faith feels more like murder
and these little deaths keep hurting
it's a long road to nowhere and there's
a good chance i'll get there
but as long as you're beside me
home is where i'll be
and there's a place inside of me where
i've never quite believed that change
was something good and always welcome
and here it is i'm torn i'm an ancient
being born in a hole inside my heart
that's always bare
and faith feels just like murder
these little deaths keep hurting me
it's a long road to nowhere there's a
good chance i'll get there but as long
as you're beside me
home
is where i'll be
so glad you're with us right here on the
dr john elon's show